the government is to ask the appeal
courts to reduce the compensation
awarded to two injured soldiers and in
just a second live experiments here at
BBC Radio Nottingham with 1 nottingham
science team still creating big bangs a
year on condition especially now and
especially as the winter months approach
and then it doesn't like to make a
little bit of money are you ready yeah
if you've ever wondered what makes glow
sticks fluorescent or why some compounds
explode when others don't
then you need actually go no further
than Nottingham because a group of
scientists and one filmmaker took the
periodic table to the internet a year
ago and they're still going strong dr.
Pete license and Samantha Tang from the
University of Nottingham here at BBC
Radio Nottingham now hi guys hi and
you've got lots of things with you in
fact there's something there is dry
Alastair something coming out with look
at the early being on a stage isn't it
we've brought the things we're allowed
to show you some of the experiments that
we've done on periodic videos so we've
got some liquid nitrogen which is very
very cold as minus 196 degrees C
slightly cooler than the average
temperature in Nottingham today we
wondered whether you might like some and
ISA bowls it's very cold but we thought
we splashed him around so you can hear
it evaporating so the liquid evaporates
make nitrogen gas everywhere what's
really cool it looks like it's boiling
just now well it is was the thing with
the balloon then just do that again so
we're just putting some liquid nitrogen
over the balloon to cool it so you can
see that it shrinks doesn't make good
radio that the stuff that's in the
balloon makes fantastic radio so then go
to periodic videos dot-com such a simple
trick we've also set up in the meantime
or Nuggets Bryce as you can hear we've
got these film canisters so these are
red now everybody
digital camera so you can't get film you
know old film canisters very easily
anymore but we've got a couple of old
ones and playing some solid carbon
dioxide which dry ice is very common
unlike other solids like ice for
instance if you left it out on the side
and melted from the puddle of water this
stuff goes straight from being a solid
it's a gas and all of this stuff is just
what you've been doing really over the
last year is about what the periodic
table is about what each one of those
little symbols that we all learned in
chemistry lessons actually does and it's
been a true education it's been
fascinating watching some of the videos
it's been great fun making them too and
we even get noticed in the street and
when we're traveling around the country
and even further afield I came back from
Australia earlier in the year
people wouldn't recognize me while I was
walking along the seafront in mad
absolutely bonkers a little film
canister exploding as the gas inside it
just expanded yeah fantastic
well and just remind us again at the
website if we want to go and have a look
at some of these experiments periodic
videos calm periodic videos calm thanks
for joining us dr. Pete license and
Samantha tang and lots of little
explosions for you on BBC Radio nothing
it's time to still go in yeah that's
cool
BBC Radio Nottingham breakfast show it's
very early in the morning you got a good
face for radio
yeah thanks buddy